>> Laura: WHAT A WAY TO BURY
A STORY.
EVERYBODY WAS READY FOR THE
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS
LAST NIGHT.
HILLARY CLINTON DROPS ON HER
FACEBOOK PAGE AT ABOUT
BOTCHING THE SEXUAL
AFTER A FEMALE CAMPAIGN
STAFF REPEATEDLY ACCUSED HER
FAITH ADVISOR OF HARASSING
HER AND HE WASN'T FIRED.
WHO IS THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK ROGUE SPOOKS
INTELLIGENCE WAR ON DONALD
TRUMP.
DICK, HILLARY CLINTON UP TO
HER OLD TRICKS.
YOU KNOW, DOCUMENT DUMP ON
FRIDAYS.
DOCUMENT DUMP RIGHT BEFORE
THE STATE OF THE UNION
SPEECH.
WHAT DO WE MAKE FROM THIS?
WHAT DO WE TAKE AWAY FROM
IT.
>> WELL, LAURA, HILLARY'S
ENTIRE PUBLIC PERSONA IS
BASED ON THIS ISSUE IS BASED
ON TWO ORIGINAL LIES.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE HAVE
DO ALL THE STUFF HE IS
ACCUSED OF DOING.
EVEN THOUGH MUCH OF IT IS
IS
DID.
THE POINT OF THOSE LIES IS
THAT SHE CANNOT ADMIT THAT
BILL DOES THIS STUFF OR THAT
SHE KNOWS ABOUT IT AND LET'S
HIM GET AWAY WITH IT.
BECAUSE HER ENTIRE POLITICAL
POWER IS DERIVATIVE.
FIRST LADIES AREN'T ELECTED.
IT'S ALL DERIVATIVE OF BEING
MARRIED TO CLINTON.
SHE IS.
AND, THEREFORE, SHE WILL DO
>> Laura: AND THIS OTHER
STORY ALSO KIND OF BUBBLED
UP TODAY IN THE GUARDIAN
NEWSPAPER.
IT WAS OLD HOME WEEK IN
CLINTON SCANDAL-O-RAMA,
DICK.
CODY SHARE.
ALL THIS STUFF COMES BACK.
CODY SHEARER SUPPOSEDLY
WROTE A SECOND DOSSIER WHICH
KIND OF CONFIRMED THE FIRST
DOSSIER AND THAT KIND OF
BLEW UP BUT OUR REPORTING
INDICATES THAT THERE IS NO
THERE THERE.
WE ARE DISCOUNTING WHAT THE
GUARDIAN REPORTED TODAY.
PUT TOGETHER ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP COULD PROBABLY BE
DISMISSED SUMMARILY?
>> WELL, CODY IS ONE OF THE
CARD-CARRYING ORIGINAL
MEMBERS OF THE BLACK OPS
TEAM THAT HILLARY CHASED
DOWN BLACKMAIL THE WOMEN WHO
BILL WAS INVOLVED TO COW
THEM INTO SILENCE.
KATHLEEN WILLEY VERY
EXPLICITLY MENTIONED HIM AS
PART OF THAT.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS
PROBABLY NOT THE SECOND
DOSSIER.
I THINK IT MAY HAVE BEEN THE
FIRST DOSSIER.
I THINK IT'S ENTIRELY
POSSIBLE THAT HILLARY AND
HER CAMPAIGN PEOPLE GOT
SHEARER TO COME UP WITH
THESE FANTASTIC STORIES,
WHICH ALL MAJOR ONES WHICH
THEM UNDER CODY SHEARER'S
NAME BECAUSE HE HAD NO
CREDIBILITY.
AT ONE POINT HE WAS ACCUSED
OF NEGOTIATING A DIPLOMATIC
SOLUTION IN BOSNIA AND HAD
TO BE REPUDIATED BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESS KNOWS ALL ABOUT
SHEARER.
YOU KNOW ALL ABOUT HIM.
>> THEY NEEDED TO FIND
SOMEONE WITH CREDIBILITY TO
BE THE FRONT MAN FOR THAT
AND THEY MAY HAVE CHOSEN
CHRISTOPHER STEELE BECAUSE
OF HIS BACKGROUND IN MI-6.
IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE THAT THE
BRITS PLAYED A ROLE IN THIS
WORKING THROUGH CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
>> Laura: OKAY.
>> WE WROTE THIS BOOK ROGUE
SPOOKS PREDICTED ALL OF
THIS.
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP BASED
IN THE FBI.
>> Laura: DEEP STATE.
DEEP STATE IS DIGGING BIG
HOLES, DICK.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU ON
RADIO TOMORROW.
>> OH, GOOD.